John boyega is officially the most
adorable stormtrooper there ever was
even if he doesn't have much competition
I'm Dave and this is you're so cute it
should be illegal news update the Star
Wars Episode seven Axl recently dressed
up as his force awakens character Finn
and visited a young boy with a brain
tumor
the little boy Daniel saw the Disney
blockbuster and asked if he along with
some of the other children at the Royal
London Hospital could meet Finn and his
wish was granted
boy eiga who delivered toys to children
during his visit said in the instagram
caption he taught Finn about everything
earth related really thankful for the
opportunity this child granted me and
I'm just humbled I hope I played a
little part in making you smile young
stormtrooper in another statement boy
Jaeger said he jumped at the chance to
make Daniel's wish come true he is an
amazing and inspirational boy and it was
a pleasure to meet him and his family it
was also great to meet the children at
the Royal London hospital and be part of
something so positive another child
laila remark that Finn's force awakens
friend ray was nowhere to be seen
not to worry though as Lela had a ray
costume ready and Ward's with boy Jaeger
and Daniel through the hospital the
wish-granting was organized by rays of
sunshine a UK's children charity that
liked make-a-wish grants wishes to
children living with serious illnesses
his Finn / John boyega your favorite
Star Wars character and an all-round
good human being yet let me know the
comments section below
or find me on Twitter I'm at a regular
Dave thanks for watching and for all
your latest news on Star Wars keep it
GameSpot calm